was stößt mehr Treibhausgas aus als
Autos Flugzeuge und Schiffe
was tötet 75 Milliarden Tiere jedes Jahr
was ist die größte Ursache des sechsten
massenaussterbens
Lebensmittel so steht es auf der Website
von replanet die in England vor kurzem
gegründete Umweltorganisation will das
75% der Erde verwildern dafür müssen
sich allerdings Grundlegendes ändern
sagt der Biologe Martin Reich deutsches
Mitglied von replanet und diese Bereiche
der Natur wieder zu befreien quasi von
unseren menschlichen Einflüssen müssen
wir Platz schaffen für für Wildnis und
das heißt andererseits dass wir weniger
Platz für unsere Landwirtschaft brauchen
müssen da müssen wir hinkommen und dafür
ist eine Revolution im Ernährungsbereich
nötig
bei Martina Reich zu Hause hat es die
bereits gegeben in einem
selbstgebastelten Bioreaktor baut er
Algen an in einem anderen Arbeiten
Mikroorganismen mit dem Kombucha Pilz
was er im kleinen macht soll mittels
Gentechnik die Lebensmittelproduktion
revolutionieren denn die seit der Zeit
einer der größten Klimakiller also wenn
man jetzt zum Beispiel aus der bei der
Kuh herausgefunden hat wie Milch da
entsteht also nein das sind ja auch
bestimmte Gene die dann da
verantwortlich sind dann kann man die in
Mikroorganismen transferieren und dann
produziert der Mikroorganismus Milch und
mit der quasi gemolken und dann hat man
Milch
die Natur um zu programmieren ist nicht
nur eine Vision von Umweltschützern
sondern wird gerade Realität in Berlin
sitzt formo ein food-start-up der Kur
hat man ein Denkmal gesetzt allerdings
als Auslaufmodell
wir produzieren Proteine die ohne das
Tier auskommen sprich ohne die Kuh weil
wir alle wissen wir brauchen dafür sehr
sehr viel Land um Tiere zu halten wir
brauchen sehr sehr viel Wasser hoher
CO2-Ausstoß
ein Imagevideo statt dreckiger
bauernstiefel Weißkittel
um Mikroorganismen Milchproteine
produzieren zu lassen mussten wir uns
das Genom der Kuh anschauen wir haben
dann die Gene identifiziert die für die
Milch verantwortlich sind und sie in
Mikroorganismen eingesetzt um Milch zu
erzeugen
ich beschreibe unsere Wissenschaftler
auch immer gerne als die modernen
Superhelden weil im Grunde genommen
Superheld heute ist nicht ein Superman
der einem Cape daher fliegt sondern
jemand der kreative Lösungsansätze
findet
[Musik]
zusammen mit ihren Labor Architekten
weit vor homo im letzten Jahr ihren
bio-reaktor ein diese Art der
Milchproduktion sei viel schneller als
die der Kühe so heißt es und nachhaltig
noch dazu die fressen mehr oder weniger
alles an kurzkettigen Kohlenhydraten das
heißt da ist man auch relativ frei und
flexibel und kann aus der
Lebensmittelindustrie potenziellen
Zukunft auch Nebenströme nutzen die
sonst kohlenhydratreiche Abfall werden
und das können das Mikroorganismen dann
verstoffwechseln
die Käserei der Zukunft ein klinisch
reines Labor formo wie 10% des
europäischen käsemarkts erobern
das ist im Prinzip der Rohstoff unser
Protein das von den Mikroorganismen
hergestellt wird und das kommt dann im
zusammen wird mit anderen
Inhaltsstoffen zusammengegeben
derzeit ist formo in der Erprobungsphase
wichtig sei nicht nur der Geschmack
sondern auch das Aussehen 50 Millionen
Euro haben Investmentfonds gegeben
hoffen auf das ganz große Geschäft und
dass sich unser Verständnis von Natur
verändert
ist es natürlich eine Kuh um ein Fünftel
ihrer Lebenszeit zu bringen ihren Euter
auf ein fünffaches wachsen zu lassen und
dann
deren Kälber wegzunehmen und ihnen Milch
zu klauen
daran ist überhaupt nichts natürlich wir
nehmen es aber als natürlich wahr und
das ist ja die eigentlich interessante
Frage was ist natürlich eigentlich und
das sollten wir uns als Gesellschaft
neue Fragen
auch die Immobilienentwickler Art
Projekt glaubt an die
lebensmittelrevolution und an einer hoch
lukrative neue Industrie
sowohl die Welt zu retten ein Stückchen
besser zu machen als auch Geld zu
verdienen und diese Kombination das ist
ja die wir haben wollen mit Fleisch wird
in Deutschland wird 70 Milliarden Euro
Umsatz gemacht und wenn wir sagen wir
müssen eigentlich die Hälfte unseres
Fleischkonsums reduzieren dann entsteht
ein Alternativen Markt von 35 Milliarden
Euro für Alternativprodukte gigantisch
viel Geld wo früher Gebrauchtwagen
verkauft wurden will man nun 200
Millionen Euro in einen sogenannten food
Campus investieren ja es ist schon ein
gigaprojekt soll Welt verändernd sein
wir wollen die die Zukunft
erlebensmittel hier
neue denken die Kraft neue Ideen ein Ort
der Lösungen Antworten
im lichtdurchfluteten foodcampus Berlin
arbeiten wissenschaftler:innen Köchinnen
lebensmitteltechnologinnen food Nerds
Techies Bauern auch an Fleisch aus dem
Reaktor wollen sie im Food Campus
forschen die neue Technik spare auch
klimaschädliche Transportwege man muss
sich das vorstellen perspektivisch wie
man heute Brauereien kennt dass dort
ähnlich wie Braukessel große
bio-reaktoren stehen und den
Lebensmittel produziert werden die
werden irgendwo am Stadtrand gebaut
werden und wird eher ein industrieller
Prozess sein als in landwirtschaftlicher
Prozess
ein Christian harmale wird im Food
Campus die Kantine bauen beim Dussmann
Konzern geht er neue Wege im Konzerne
eigenen Restaurant so wie derzeit mit
Eiern die eigentlich keine Eier sind die
Firma perfekt produziert sie aus Erbsen
Eier sind einfach so ein beliebtes
tierisches Protein wir müssen das Huhn
rausnehmen aus der Gleichung also ich
glaube wir wissen alle dass man die
Rechnung am Teller nicht mehr ohne den
Planeten machen können das was wir an an
Produktion die letzten 20 30 Jahre auf
den Teller gebracht haben war nicht
immer nachhaltig beim food Campus
vergleichen Sie die ernährungswände mit
der industriellen Revolution und um
Industrie wird es dabei gehen nicht um
idyllische Bauernhöfe Aktivisten sagen
nachhaltig sei wichtiger als natürlich
auch der Biolandbau Fresse Flächen und
schade den Klima es werden am Ende Tanks
sein in den Dinge produziert werden ich
denke auch nicht dass man das ähm zu
sehr kaschieren sollte sondern von
Anfang an auch thematisieren sollte dass
man weiß wenn man jetzt effizienter oder
oder anders ist dass man dadurch Natur
schützt also quasi also eher die Wildnis
die dann dafür steht wenn man es
natürliches Geld will als Bauernhof
nur einen Haken hat das ganze das neue
Essen wird viel Strom brauchen für all
die bio-reaktoren aber auch darauf haben
die neuen Umweltaktivisten eine Antwort
Atomenergie